welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
live on twitch.tv for slash h3h3
productions today we have a very special
impromptu episode I'll tell you what
we've been thinking about doing the show
twice per week we're thinking about
bringing a Tuesday episode to you guys
where we have a top of the week where
we've discussed what's going on in the
world have some laughs have some goofs
just me and ela hanging out maybe
sometimes some some people come and hang
with us but on Friday we have the
interviews and our traditional stuff
there but I think it would be bring a
good balance to have like our us time
and you know that all of us time it's
like the top of the month but top of the
week yeah top of the month we cram
everything into one episode ends up
being like three-hour marathon we could
do that every week be more current have
some laughs along the way every week so
here's basically our pilot attempt to do
that and I'm thinking about cutting it
down making about like an hour-long each
episode something about that about that
length so yeah that's what we're
thinking so let's give it a shot and a
quick quick thank you we have enough
sponsors today so our real and only
sponsors as it has always been is the
wonderful people on Twitch prime and our
subscribers on Twitch you guys are my
heart and soul okay and when I lay in
bed at night with ela I'm not thinking
about her I'm thinking about you guys
I'm saying she's cool I like her but my
twitch prime subs that's who I'm
freaking I disappeared on to of that
message so ela - she act like she's I
know you think about her twitch prime
says act like that's not your family
everybody of those emoticons and I go to
sleep more emoticons so anyway thank you
everybody supports the show let's get
into it yeah a couple things on my chest
I want to get off first and foremost
before we get into the memes mm-hmm I'm
back on Fupa loss right you know I did
was do it really good I was up to 205
when you start when I was at my fattest
yeah
I was a monster I did really good you
got sick lost the progress yeah that's
the killer
hopefully I got to stay healthy but I
was so fat at the onset like I don't
know if I talked about this but I was so
of such a monster man like I would lean
over to tie my shoes and I would
couldn't breathe
like that's not a joke like it was a
large it was big Shh you know I stopped
wearing tennis shoes only sneakers only
bands stop wearing tent why cuz I'm
gonna tie I couldn't totally I was like
this is not how animals are meant to
live on this earth especially not in
their thirties well that's like someone
in their 70s yeah man they're deep fella
nobody nobody know of age age aside you
shouldn't suffocate to lean down to your
foot and I actually felt my ribs being
pushed out of my body I'm like this fat
this [ __ ] disgusting food I'm eating
every day is terraforming my body
the ribs are being displaced by the fat
so I had this moment of realization I'm
like all right dude time to time to get
on that football off so I lost 10 pounds
I want to lost like 15 oh and uh and
then I got sick like you said and I was
like f [ __ ] it
as I got [ __ ] my life well when you're
sick you can't exercise and then you
start also eating whatever because you
don't feel well yeah you need color you
need that comfort feel vulnerable and
then it's so hard to get back to it so
right and then eventually you lose your
rhythm and you're like f [ __ ] [ __ ] my
life by this cheeseburger is more
important than being me living over the
age of 50 is that strange
I'm fully a food addict like it's
straight you people are like oh you're
addicted the hair when you're addicted
to meth alcohol these problems I'm a
food addict and I'm kicking that
addiction yeah when I could when I went
well my ribs are being pushed out of my
body and I'm feel it and I'll still go
eat a cheeseburger and french fries
that's an addiction that's sick when you
start to get uncomfortable in your own
body right so maybe do something about
that yeah take it take your things very
uncomfortable it's uncomfortable it's
disgusting and it's unhealthy but it's
hard to make that change I mean I see
when you're really trying and I see how
hard it is to do that way it's like the
most annoying thing but on one hand it's
like it's good to acknowledge it as an
addiction it should give you some more
sympathy for people who suffer from
being like a you know a fat [ __ ]
monster right to put it sensitively it's
effective or not more I will have that
much like oh [ __ ] eejit whale
difference and fighting to get back to
the ocean but it's good to think about
it as an addiction right you don't say
yeah dammit stop just stop doing heroin
you're you know I mean you got to think
about complicated and complication yeah
complicated so anyway I've been doing
good I've been exercising hard man I've
been hitting that that elliptical mm-hmm
I've been dieting I go to bed starving I
don't know if that's record but that's
how you do it but I I don't know I need
to see results quick otherwise I get
discouraged
so I'll starve myself I called the
concentration camp diet just like it is
the start of my son to write a book I
don't know just carve my book will be
banned in America fat so the fat cow
monsters of America maybe what a
concentration camp diet that'll be the
title everyone's gonna love it anyway I
woke up this morning super hungry
because I hit the gym last night by that
I mean the elliptical machine and I was
starving because I went to bed hungry
and we've got a Starbucks and I'm always
looking for like a healthy alternative
for the food and they have this one item
called the I always [ __ ] crack up
when I say I can't take people seriously
it's called the feta cheese egg white
white sliced tortilla wrap like a whole
run-on sentence then egg white spinach
fettuccine we trapped and it's like you
have to say like whimsically and they're
like all right sir and if you if you try
to like not say the full thing they
always like what yeah what say it so
this is really shame you say it like
with the coffee sighs I refuse to say
their names
so every time like I want a small coffee
so they're like oh you wonder the recipe
it is socially needed that's what that
okay I know this is like this has been
running to the ground about Starbucks
but seriously what the [ __ ] small a
large medium and I don't I don't play by
the rules I'm a rebel okay I might get
the feta egg white spinach tortellini
but I refuse to say [ __ ] tall or
grande I want a medium coffee you know
what I mean
don't make me say anyway I get this diet
food back it's just such a con this
health food didn't they give you this
egg white and it's like oozing with like
butter and cheese and they're like oh
there's spinach in it that's healthy and
it's like little flakes of spinach that
was sauteed in butter you know and I'm
eating this more eating this on the way
over and I'm like she's the one I want
him you ever eat a meal and you're like
I would be better off not having put
this in my body yes a lot I think that a
lot I would my body would be healthier I
would be healthier in life if I just
straight-up didn't eat this meal so I
felt about it a little bit all right
and
pretty good I'm I'm a fan of eating at
home so for me almost every time I get
out it's how I feel
say that again I just I like eating at
home like you just can't compare that to
food you get outside yeah I know what's
in there you got fresh fresh vegetables
you know what yo you know when you eat
out it's like I don't know what how I
got this food and what happened in the
product and some chef who was back there
who doing wiped his [ __ ] hands if ya
[ __ ] his finger broke through the baby
wipe and he's like that
or like when you're at home you have
this thing you have like this mix of
lettuce and stuff and it's got a date on
it and if it's one day pass we like to
throw it out I freak out throw it I
don't know if they do it in the
restaurant yeah you may be eating like a
two-week-old yeah
well probably are when you get a head of
lettuce and you washing the little bugs
and grime out do they do that they're
busy people probably not so yeah I don't
like eating out either and so that you
know that's my rant for the morning
pretty much cover everything on the
agenda they're moving on to the next
story here top story you guys probably
saw this it was a really special mean
this was circulating on Twitter
everywhere the Joey salads is a [ __ ]
Nazi memes oh good thank God okay so on
Twitter
somebody originally tweeted out
something like to those of you who say
Trump supporters aren't Nazis look at
this picture I'm in [ __ ] erase
windows I hate windows so much Bill
Gates you make it cure malaria but
you'll never make me not want to flip
and kick a wall anyway so somebody
tweets out you know to people who say
not all Trump supporters are not to look
at this picture and it's Joey salad corn
anachronism oh for [ __ ] sake Joey of
course and then everybody starts
retweeting this and it starts picking it
up this makes your choice colleges at
the Nazi what does that guy should say
Obama called me
Klinger Hillary calls me up
horrible terrorist call me infidel Trump
calls me American that's a little
dramatic dude but regardless you have
Joey cells standing next to the swats
gonna sleeve you seem very reasonable so
this is from a prank from like months
ago and the media picks it up and
everyone's like oh [ __ ] that's Joey
South we don't really look into it
obviously who looks at anything these
days
except me so people thought he was that
they're at their Island Charlotte's
right last week so you guys probably
follow this whole thing in
Charlottesville where there was like a
white supremacist who freaking ran over
people I mean if you're if you have to
be living under a rock not to have heard
about that I really nothing to add to
that it hasn't even said bye everybody
but everybody thought Joey salads was
there and I'm not see Swasey and
everyone's like what the [ __ ] Joey -
territory de nasi and so obviously you
know he's not a Nazi he's just a salad
head I know that looks you guys know
that my no and it's from a prank for a
months ago let me watch it I got it here
yeah what was the prank about yes so he
prank was about not see a trump rally
social experiment our Trump supporters
Nazis here's a here's a brief excerpt
from that video reaching out to we're
enough to welcome to be Romeo over there
on that side where we don't see it right
it was a dilemma
oh [ __ ] I'm getting used to this group
format I don't say there you go
we should get you a mouse yeah Mouse
would be helpful so here it is people
over there on that side they've been
telling us reaching out to we renounced
you you're welcome to be here we can't
stop you but I don't know why you're
doing this but it's not a cosplayer we
do not agree with bridge out there I
thought I thought we were Nazis said
that people are their class not the
sword
truck let's work let's do see that you
have ready I don't think your exact but
the left a name there I thought we were
the Nanshan says that they all said no
we're literally killing mr. butcher but
they say all right well that was a good
job you get I got a whole new context
after the eyes wake of it what do you
mean well I just if you went like that
to the Raleigh oh that would be a really
bad timing to do that experiment yeah
there a chance they'd be like let's go
do it come on here's your shield
here's your shield is ours I think
here's your ticket George do it can you
imagine Joey like fish out of water like
anyway it turns out it actually had like
a relatively nice message yeah he went
out there and he's a he's an idiot guys
was he real about it you know we love
him to death to tell that he goes out
there and he's like hey we're Nazis
right Heil Hitler
and they're like no dude what the [ __ ]
wrong with you wrong event wrong in here
at the wrong event good okay so actually
a relatively heartwarming show of
rebuking him and the Nazis they're not
that I think that Trump supporters are
Nazis was just it was a nice see but on
the other hand you kind of have to
accept that when you go out into the
world just as a Nazi Joey
kinda hard to explain I should ask
PewDiePie it's tough to get away with
those jokes all right but now there's
just been a huge media blitz about how
Joey cells is the Nazi units everywhere
yeah is kind of like shouldn't joke
around with this stuff I guess
especially after all these things
happening lately this was before I know
but now it's really not always loved it
yeah so when we shout out to our
favorites a little not want appreciate
you
dead air next up Jake Paul drops the mic
literally Jay Paul hosted and performed
at the Teen Choice Award that's kind of
shocking to me
it's hard to imagine a world where Jake
Paul is actually below I mean I know he
is but the disconnect that big Teen
Choice Awards on Nickelodeon would I
know he won two awards he was nominated
for he hosted the dang thing he
performed I mean I was just those pins I
don't know a Teen Choice Award what how
far up the teen are we going because I
feel like there it got about 15 yeah I
think our fans are like 12 should be the
adolescence Awards I guess it all falls
under the same thing probably should be
the dependents Awards Sherwood should be
the mom bring me a juice box or worse
anyway Jake Paul drops the mic literally
hey guys let it go but I am forgetting
let me drag this over actually you guys
can see it it's every day bro
[Music]
oh thank you Dan it's everyday go
it's everyday so that's it this
motorbike
I like that jump that is good a little
leap really went for it also I like that
he word everyone
he made it everyone else wear red and
he's in blue I guess it's his home he's
the star the star users it he is the CEO
of 10 team 10 just slick don't get it
twisted don't get it twisted
I love that when he dropped the mic the
sound didn't change at all
how's that work some kind of black magic
by the way I guess I can announce this
now because it's pretty official at this
point but this Friday
guess who's our guest every day my dogs
we've got a white a [ __ ] episode
planned for this Friday you will not
want to miss Jake Paul is coming in and
are you sure you want to miss tell them
the surprise huh yeah why not okay and a
KTLA reporter that you know broke this
story about Jake Paul is coming in as
well it's going to be a blockbuster my
friends I'm excited and I think it's
gonna be I think it's going to be a
fascinating I think we need up there
yeah your load we found one or more
settings on your battery that will help
improve your life I plugged it I don't
care about the battery I don't care
about update I don't care but one on it
off a Windows everyday by the way every
day tomorrow right [ __ ] I didn't know
Bill Gates would love Jake multiband
updates
getting killed out there I'm getting
[ __ ] hammered Vin Diesel yeah a
[ __ ] dead
and that voice is something on her
alright so Ben this is kind of a old
clip but I haven't seen before it's
becoming my favorite clip get ready
where's my mouth Vin Diesel professes
love for a Brazilian youtuber during an
interview get a load of this [ __ ] man to
the first one that can't be his real
voice that's the first one me thank you
to blame that is it up guy so beautiful
my right eye wrong look how am I
supposed to do is and if you look at
this woman tell me she's so beautiful
go mad and sing the better price how's
that in real life there's no way
hey not even speak in English he's just
like low rumbling why have you never
seen a woman he's never seen a woman
before it think you play it just got
here from Mars but never seen a scene on
the farm
I'm too black
talk to me baby so this book values
within God what God on account of you
thank you you probably just motorboats
them he does probably as a micropenis
and it gets women off he goes down on
them goes
[Music]
hey guys good god and he kind of told me
was gonna be like and the last thing I
wanted I saw a new speaking I am Groot
in so many languages but I don't know if
you ever send it in Portuguese so I
brought you what you think about help
they're so good
who's what do you think about a delta
I'm a fan of the sleeveless shirts in
all kinds I know you're a big fan well
you're the Fashion Police healer you're
the Guru what do you let me give them a
critique your Joan Rivers on the red
carpet what do you say to the guy it's
just so it's so madhouse Wow it's just
wow it's such a parkour guy cut off
plaid aviator glasses but can you keep
playing it sounds like I can't get
another fitted to go so Gooch can you
believe that Tiffany was David guys I
don't know what this thing is look at
her what do you want
it's so crazy do you think you smashed
it is like what's wrong I don't know
what is wrong you're doing everybody
jumping over the couches and drop the
cameras to come try to [ __ ] put their
dick on this girl it's crazy
I've never seen anything like yeah I've
never seen anything like it I don't
think he has to try that hard either
he's a movie star and I mean yeah well
things on point
his voice is on point I'm getting
rock-hard just from the vibrations of
the bass in the room is make my dick of
grow she's so [ __ ] beautiful it's
like you can't even do it
get away very wrong
oh my god someone save you with the
beautiful world beautiful world when
this turn the beautiful world
open your eyes yes looking at us and we
just join in a beautiful world I think
she's our girl oh yeah as soon as he got
out of a shooter and as soon as he got
up it's like oh [ __ ]
stay where you are moving do you think
he [ __ ] her she ran she look creep out
of my hand and I wait here's part 2
there's a sequel to this OHS it's just
OT MP Harris backstage
[Music]
she does seem weirded out by it yeah we
got drugs I mean it I mean we almost
changed I don't know I love what he's
having I want to enter beautiful world
are you sure who is big no I don't know
actually I'm not sure why it's a
beautiful world he put on a camera
nice little changes what what was that
their intro now show to give a she's a
[ __ ] so anyway I identified that was
an interesting one this is crazy
I've seen Vin Diesel in interviews and I
liked him really I haven't that's my
first clue he plays like Dungeons &
Dragons and [ __ ]
he's like a nerd so it's just hiring
something here maybe something is wrong
well I mean are I mean did you not see
her love is a drug they say you
[Laughter]
sometimes I go to her in my office I'm
patent owner all right thank you for
that down what else we got on deck here
my friends Mike Tyson in an interview
this is an interesting one because it
curious what your your take us on this
one having seen this yeah this one's
good this is a good video
so Mike yeah it's called Mike Tyson
swears on TV but that's really not even
the point of the video
welcome back many of you probably know
that Mike Tyson come I do which
happiness in a pound he met up with
Mayor Rob Ford he joins us right now
with this promoter Alex Henry joining us
both of you and I'll go with yourself
many are wondering how does that happen
this meeting was in there I'm going to
inside clothing again I know the end of
the day is mayor of the city Mike Tyson
is here to promote the first ever
performance in Canada and when I had
Sugar Ray Leonard come to Montreal the
mantra when
the mayor's office we're here to have it
we both community in the history of
Ronald with a man and bigger denotes
those city you can select a name but in
the city of Amman conceived again and in
our community and dynamic character
arrested you he read up on any server
call Nigeria one my watched on
television but in M using a big big
instinct and what some of your critics
would say yelled is a race for mayor
we know you're a convicted rapist this
can hurt it campaign how would you
respond to that
hey how does it the United you know
means and how animal commandeer you know
because we can tell that off you call
what happen Mike Tyson's if a convicted
rapist right and that happened a long
time ago and it was crowded in
controversy it was his girlfriend who
accused him of right and you know it's
he went to prison for it ended his
career mm-hmm you know nobody want it's
very controversial T so anyway this
guy's like your convicted rapist what do
you say to the people who say it so it
doesn't it's not a good look for him for
the mayor to be hanging out with you
mmm-hmm that Mike [ __ ] loses it and I
think understandably it's kind of a
[ __ ] like curveball right begs would
come in Toronto having a good time so
you're a convicted rapist
and this is after you spend time oh this
is for never like fifteen years yeah
okay nobody nobody you know please that
[ __ ] doesn't come up really but anyway
it's on live television and he's out
here trying to promote his live show
they're on tour there I don't know it's
kind of I don't know here's I'll
continue thank you this ue- stop and I
found Mittman I'm missing here nothing
to do about it
time we talked about Georges Seurat oh
it is remoter tease my great happiness
my life and going to the time yes but it
like napkins my emotion we should be
open to make that was really a piece of
[ __ ] you are doing too much TV on can't
you what are you there - only you are
like we are I think we are we're gonna
draw it's the real paralyzed easier to
see your show the tells it about you
know it's people kind of hard to
pressure my dad today our pre-production
one can be friends like I'm calm be calm
I and we're really really from yeah it's
like is a human being what you brought
it up and now you want him to just move
on and go back to like all smiley mode
it's yeah a little hard no that's not
that question it's not the right set
it's not the right type of player but I
love I mean look I don't know for my
crate I don't know you know I have no
patience for rapist obviously but the
mic one was pretty controversial it's a
time is a time I mean like someone I
don't know it's kind of tricky you hear
but anyway mike is such character yeah
yes we're looking at me on the gorillas
over it's over tonight we're going to be
looking for our last right it is
nerve-racking Beauty some like this
there's a more nervous for you box
[Music]
it's not no rhymes medias talking to a
reputation oh look at it French sling
are you I love it
mike is a words in it good for him
I love Mike Tyson for the firm we're all
people like if you're gonna ask him a
mensch it still with the query I think
it's better to not be like oh well my
shooting tonight is going to be great
I'm more nervous boxing than performing
and you just called me a rapist if
anything it's more humanizing of Mike
because it shows that wasn't just
something I didn't already forgot about
it
doesn't matter if he did it or not but
obviously it was the dark thing in his
life yeah and you don't just bring it up
playback me Mike Tyson is one of the
most interesting people really Jude has
been through so much he had such a rough
upbringing was the champion by like 19
went to prison for rape controversy
surrounded in controversy came out his
career was over
and then his daughter [ __ ] had a
freak death did you know that until you
told his daughter like fell out of a
window or so or at some freak no it
wasn't even that it was like totally
outside of his control dan can you look
that I'll tell you anyway and here she
died in a tragic accidents on a
treadmill mom that's why a hanging
accident involving a treadmill like
something that never foresee her prevent
her daughter dies like and that [ __ ]
like I don't know man he's an
interesting guy dude I love the way he
talks yes faster it is fascinating and I
like one of my favorite quotes of all
time he's talking [ __ ] to this boxer on
live on live TV and he says to the guy
I'm gonna [ __ ] you till you love me [ __ ]
yeah I mean that's just so beautifully
stated as an insult I can't think of
anything better just at the top of your
head I mean it's just it's beautiful so
anyway this was a good one dude scares
the wrong lady this one's a little old
triggering these people kind of pissed
me off let's have a look alright so you
know thanks this guy looks like a class
act already
he'll at Miller High Life hat with that
ain't it so bent the deeper the bend the
more the inbred is what they say looks
like he's missing a couple teeth
[Music]
this lady is dying she's horrified his
girlfriend is taking the ship way too
lightly you gonna show her face again
can you throw my god look okay she's
hyperventilating hello he's like oh my
god I'm so sorry
let me go put this on youtube and not
blur your face I'm so sorry great
there's a world out there my friends
with people with bent hats hats bent way
more than is reasonable scaring people
in batten hallways filming them
I'm telling you me on the world that
there's crazy it's crazy back me up on
that you yep
thanks when you got support like that
let me tell ya the world is my oyster
this show is on tappable what else we
got here got some other stories Disney
is pulling out all of its content from
Netflix Hulu Amazon every streaming
platform Disney's pulling out you know
just like my dad wishes he did bad jokes
kind of it's still a little too sexual
for a joke but I see your point is kind
of they're in the same thing yeah early
bad yeah early dad joke free fatherhood
so they're pulling out and my first
thought was like whoa good luck idiots
you know but Disney owns but wait
they're pulling out because the other
starting their own streaming platform
right yeah they're starting their own
streaming platform and give me a [ __ ]
break
how many of these companies are so
entitled to our ten dollars per month
I'm not I can you break I can't even
count all them memberships we have four
stop playing like a thousand dollars a
month and like random ten ten member
dollar membership fees yeah every time
and it's getting to the point where it's
kind of defeating the whole purpose so
you have these streaming flat platforms
to combat piracy and cable cable
television which nobody our age has
super expenses like $120 a month for
like got Church sports at home shopping
and like three channels you actually
watch you're actually watching
commercials with sports commercials with
yeah cable doesn't make sense to me as a
product anymore you paid way more money
$120 a month and then they it's half of
it is like super intense commercials
yeah so then you have these streaming
platforms they're blowing up they're
competing with cable I'm paying Netflix
Hulu Amazon between those three I'm
paying like 30 dollars a month but it
just starts they're paying like show
time to watch yeah you know there's
there's all kinds until I can Ollie okay
show time I play playstation yeah and
your crunchyroll I hey everybody way I
shouldn't take much role I don't I'm not
a weeaboo I'm kidding I love country
don't be ashamed I'm kidding anyway so
now it's coming to the point where all
these companies think that they're worth
[ __ ] that all of our money it's
becoming so fragmented to bread to
YouTube right like we have so many I'm
just trying to check right now yeah you
pay iTunes right I know it's crazy
it's getting to the point where we might
as well just get cable although a
different way yeah but it's becoming so
fragmented all these companies being
like oh my shits [ __ ] worth every
[ __ ] the consumer i'm disney we make it
we make skids content but we're run by
sociopaths i'm disney it's becoming so
fragmented that it's like it's defeating
the purpose yeah anyway so i'm like oh
[ __ ] off disney I'm not buying your crap
I'm still not buying the crap button
just to give you an idea of how much
property they actually oh they own Pixar
everything Pixar's ever made Lucasfilm
Star Wars Marvel everything Marvel ABC
what you know all those and all those
late night shows you watch even those
might be owned by Disney oh [ __ ]
because they own ABC they own an A&E
Network History Channel lifetime blaze
crime and I'm all into the crime and
investigation network ESPN a lot of
people care about that touchstone
pictures there's way more than that oh
and AAA they had that good Scientology
serious I just don't see it though cuz
it's like it's mostly kids content
Disney I feel like but then you have a
lot of other serious films and it's just
it's weird who's it for
yeah it's gonna be a weird collection of
stuff just [ __ ] off don't they have
enough money yes in short yes but they
do have enough money
Star Wars made like 10 trillion dollars
in it in its first day no but it did
make like a billion dollars in its
opening weekend like you're fine
Disney did the Disney executives are
sociopaths I'm not kidding Herbalife you
guys know about this company it's like
this giant like a pyramid scheme scheme
company and so covered in the disguise
of being with the name of that
documentary and I'll remember but they
say they have products for like betting
on 0 yeah they have this health product
apparently they sell like shakes and
that kind of stuff but it's all just a
skin well it's
well it's a pyramid scheme so
essentially it's this veil and but it's
not even about selling the products
right that's what makes a good pyramid
scheme yeah the product isn't actually
the product the product is the
affiliation where you have to go recruit
people to sell under you you know sue
pyramid scheme and so basically this
company Herbalife was like you know a
little bit of an underground pyramid
scheme and then like ten years ago this
guy who rose to the ranks of one of the
head directors of Disney got hired by
Herbalife to take over and this guy
turns it into like this worldwide scheme
and I seen this guy in this documentary
betting 2-0 is really interesting I
recommended a liar and I'm looking at
this guy dude and man ie could just ease
as a sociopath that guy would put poison
and baby food and go to bed at night and
sleep like an angel it probably does
it's wild this is the kind of guy who
would give your [ __ ] Nana tumble down
the stairs and say goodnight to his
children because some gimmick is I mean
I'm telling anyway that's neither here
nor there to be honest but the point is
I don't like Disney I don't trust them
and if you guys are looking for your
next spokesman I'm available you can
contact me I love her making content and
set us up anytime Disney actually
everyone I know who's worked for Disney
which I have some friends who have they
all hire right now not fired but they
all unanimously hate it they're like
they're their slave drivers just I've
you got to love the irony of this Daisy
Disney work for us work your work your
bones to the dust anyway streaming
services man not there's nothing we
can't we don't deserve anything good is
everything good in this world gets
destroyed
eventually the Internet is being [ __ ]
over by Comcast search Comcast on Google
a Nazi swastika comes up streaming
services by Disney
give me a [ __ ] your bright leave
something for me
the distribution of wealth in this
country is already [ __ ] your truck if
you want to not see your head on a
freaking guillotine like the French
Revolution leave our streaming platforms
alone it's all we have
I'm to foster the people can you making
are you starting a revolution yeah I
might be
Disney listen to my call this is not a
threat for violence it's just a joke and
if you are like a first spokesman i'ma
go anyway what's up next oh man this
story is awesome thank you Elon Musk
Elon Musk I love this guy man
Elon Musk I would probably if he was
like yo Doug here's my dick I need you I
knew it I said we going before you said
I wasn't you thought I was gonna say so
he wants me to shine it and manicure it
look I need you to manscape my genitals
I'm not doing Joe
I don't require payment I love the guy
some people hate him I don't know why
he's like the real-life Tony Stark all
right it really is I mean come on the
guy's incredible he's he's pioneered
commercial space travel opens the doors
for so many things that guy has made
driving electric vehicles cool clicking
point where he made a profit and now
he's making them consumable the model 3
mark my words
in 2 or 3 years when that [ __ ] is goes
into mass production you're going to see
that all across the country people say
people always say oh oh well electric
vehicles are just as wasteful as gas oh
I've got a [ __ ] stick in my ass and I
have to complain and be sour and
contraband contrary about everything not
true SolarCity lungs even got that I'm
getting to the righthand accomplishments
if you have a if you have a car without
an exhaust but let's get it let's just
put aside the question of is the you
know production and making new cars
whatever yeah
people always make new cars okay forget
about that even if producing the
electricity now from a freaking coal
plant is just as polluting as putting
gasoline in your car
first of all gas you can as solar and
wind and all these renewable energies
that don't give off any pollutants
become more you know cost-effective as
they do every year you have the option
to plug that [ __ ] into your car yeah you
plug that in from the outlet to your car
okay
coal gasoline you can't do that dude and
if you think that in a hundred years
risk of me doing gas if you think that's
just an option forever get [ __ ] real
tears ten year give it ten I give it ten
years too but people like oh it's just
as polluting to make a lecture card and
I was always talking about
oh it's inevitable electric cars
nobody's done it nobody stepped up to
the [ __ ] plate and risk their ass to
do it until he did he's the guy who did
it and seriously when electric cars are
[ __ ] everywhere he's going to be the
guy who did it I mean I know you really
took a huge risk what is all his money
right yeah
I'm just locally invested in it and it
didn't go well in the beginning
everybody said was going to fail the
regulators were against him that they
still don't let him have dealerships
he sells direct that model doesn't exist
almost in car manufacturing you have to
go the website and buy it you have to
wait like six months to get in a car
that's how good of a product and how
good people want you know it's insane
that the odds were stacked against the
guy and beyond that and also just for
the record the electric vehicle has an
effective 100 miles per gallon right now
so [ __ ] off haters don't ever say that
to me again don't ever talk to me or my
hair again mm-hmm it's don't talk to me
on my Elan don't ever talk to deer might
you on again and
and then furthermore he has his company
SolarCity which just got absorbed into
Tesla it's one company now but the guy
let me show you this [ __ ]
I mean Tesla we're we're in both company
he's our company's his so yeah but they
I don't know why they absorbed it own to
tell I think what happened was his
cousin or someone had ok was a
co-founder of of Solar City and he just
absorbed it ok look at this look at this
house you want to know what the [ __ ]
going on with the future look at this
house look ordinary deal these shingles
here art oh my god click here if it's a
doctor's gotta know these these roofing
that you see here is solar panels you
guys that's solar out that's powering
the house charging the car completely
off the grid hmm ok and his goal with
this is to make it better looking more
adorable durable and cheaper and she and
eventually cheaper so that it's like
people don't even have the choice and it
looks amazing
do you see this guy he's [ __ ]
changing the world like people always
talk about it like it's inevitable this
guy's how does one guy do all this it's
crazy he's amazing he's he's he's like
uh he they do yeah this is where he's
these once and a hundred when a thousand
year a guy who caught the rolls around
and just you know beats and [ __ ] beat
the [ __ ] out of the earth you know I
have so much every I don't know i man I
have a friend who's like I don't like
him I don't trust him I'm like a baby
and one of our best friends
I get so triggered fun and you got no
function there's no basis to the head it
just don't you just hate him
so even put so here's his beef with him
he's working on this other project
called um the boring company he says
again this is Elon he sees a huge
problem traffic in Los Angeles traffic
as you know if you don't live in Los
Angeles traffic is impossible if you
have never been here it's hard to
believe how bad it is
yeah I thought coming from Tel Aviv I
thought we've had like horrible traffic
it's a joy
oh my god it's nothing compared to here
give me an idea to write to drive like
20 miles it takes like an hour during
the day do we sometimes just consider
not going places because of traffic like
it's one of the it's how you make
decisions here yeah exactly and it's
funny because if you go somewhere like
past eleven when the traffic is gone
it'll take you 15 minutes to get
somewhere where it will actually take
you an hour or more during at it so he's
like okay traffic what's up with traffic
right so the dude is drilling [ __ ]
tunnels under the freeway to transport
like a superhighway for cars so it took
your car drops under and a highway and
it goes on like a conveyor belt and it
blasts you at higher you yeah there's
really everybody you can get Michelle
interesting to see boring companies
video and it blasts you at high speed
here at watch this video this is great
those tunnel tunnels look pretty wild
yeah it's pretty loud it's actually not
what I expected yeah it works so there's
basically platforms you drive on to and
it lowers you underground and it just
blunt and then here you go there's like
super highways underground that bypass
the traffic and the roads and it
launches you out like 100-plus miles per
hour and then it lets you up so the car
is not even note yeah the car doesn't
run it's on a plug you're not even
putting mileage on your car right oh it
goes 200 km/h they aren't as fast it's
funny the future is so not what people
imagine in some ways in some flying cars
because when you look at like the future
yeah you imagine stuff in the air yeah
don't actually imagine digging under an
earth yeah so my favorite part about all
of this is that he called it the boring
company yeah and so Jeannie is so good
um anyway it's just an idea obviously he
did start drilling he look people are
saying oh it's not happening Lowell
people always said that to Elon you
think you oughta listen you haters
googas ition boring company drill you
already built a [ __ ] one-of-a-kind
well even if it doesn't happen at least
the guys trying tell me it's not
happening look at these pictures try to
tell me this shit's not happening look
at this [ __ ] drill thing that I miss
epic here this is how it works it's like
this crazy stated our drill wow it's not
happening look at them lowering the
drill into a pan and look at this it's
not happening they says it's not
happening they says get real if Elon
wills it let it happen
why anyway our friend was like oh I
don't like this because it's like class
warfare
all the rich people get a superhighway
and all the poor people have to be on
the freeway I'm like dude stop that
still means less people on the freeway
first of all less traffic on the freeway
and oh my god
toll roads already [ __ ] exist dude
yeah stop anyway I'm going to be honest
we got a Tesla recently-released thing I
said was I'm not into having nice cars I
never was we had a Prius that was all I
ever wanted but it's more about just
like [ __ ] supporting this this
movement that I love about going
eco-friendly it's sick I mean I like the
car the cars dope I really like it but
it's like there's no exhaust pipes on
the car you plug it in in your garage
you wake up every morning with a full
tank of gas
it's cool man I like it why do you like
to Tesla I actually really like it it's
funny I thought that it was like so
unnecessary because we had the Prius and
right like my doing in this and I
thought it it's just going to be another
car but it's actually really cool and
I'm not obviously this is not like I
paid anything I'll say I'm sorry okay
but it is really cool they make some new
stuff that I never thought of before
like the gas and brake and we'll add on
it so much I don't know if you want to
explain it so they have what's called um
one pedal driving this is actually one
of my favorite features yeah mine too
so unexpected that I would love it that
first it's really awkward and weird so
the gas pedal when you take your foot
off the gas it breaks yeah actually it
breaks you still have the brake too so
yeah sometimes you need to like slow
down fast and you know whatever you have
a brake but it's pretty intense when you
take your foot off the gas so 90% of the
time I don't even need the brake yeah
and it's used to regenerate energy for
the battery too and also I've just
notice that it's so much more immediate
when you're braking or slowing down that
it feels a lot safer I think so when I'm
when I Drive our Prius now and I take my
foot off the gas and it's almost like it
you go yeah gliding at the same speed on
my foot because if you need to react
immediately there's a few SEC's yes yeah
it's crazy and then you know you know
Yvonne's not satisfied just to make an
electric car the self-driving is like
let's sprinkle that [ __ ] in there too
and it works amazingly all right this
morning I was having a little breakfast
in the car you put on auto drive in the
traffic and like I'm good dude I eat my
my breakfast my coffee I've got an auto
drive it's sick it feels safe because
the car so responsive I like it a lot
but more than that I just like
supporting the the movement it's
obviously an expensive car I think when
the model 3 comes out which is the it's
like more than half the price of that
one then I'm good I can't wait for the
solar roofs to become like the
mainstream they're available but now
it's probably expensive yeah it's
expensive as [ __ ] but you know he's out
there he's shaking his dick but it needs
welding almost everyone had well not
everyone but a lot of them the majority
of the houses have solar heater for the
water so when you shower and you take a
hot water you know a hot shower you turn
on the I mean if it's if it's in the
summer you don't need to turn it on
because it's always on the Sun and I've
always loved it like it's just such a
simple great thing it's so weird I mean
you have hot water it's after being in
Israel for five years it's crazy to
think that that's not everything in
America
yeah and it's always been in I don't
know why it's such a thing like you if
you ever get a shot from above you'll
see that every roof has a solar panel
around the old one and I read a report
that it cuts down on like six or eight
percent of energy consumption from the
country's power grid that's significant
yeah an LA that would work me anyway
we're getting there it's inevitable
I see more more solar power
every day when I'm coming to LA so he
lon I got your back dude I got your dick
I don't know if he wants that but he
does scare me and this gets into the
point I wanted to talk about Neal I'm
starting to freak me the [ __ ] out
because he's talking about AI he's been
in the news a lot talking about the
dangers of artificial intelligence
saying that it poses a greater threat
than North Korea is the greatest
existential crisis we've ever faced as a
species that we need to start regulating
it like drugs and weapons and stuff like
that he said something like if you're
not worried about AI you should be right
it's like oh [ __ ] I wasn't worried about
it until you said it I know I mean but
it's like here's a guy who I trust and
Mayer talked about it like that kind of
does spook me a little bit so just to
give you a little background that he
owns a company called open AI and
they're basically just testing the
limits of how far can they take AI and
so the International is a dota
tournament that took place recently the
best dota players in the world so dota
is like a competitive game where two
teams of players fight each other on an
arena of some sort and it's a very high
level skill based game with a lot of
chaos a lot is happening a lot of data
to understand and crunch kind of like
Starcraft right yeah like Starcraft it's
like chess real-time chess and so they
are like well this is a good this is a
good platform to to test this BOTS to
test this AI because if it can excel at
this and be humans then that's a good
place to start right it's like a
real-time chess game I've seen people
say it's more difficult than chess well
it's more complex I think from a from a
computer standpoint definitely because
there's way more unknown just moving
partners up yeah you know so basically
they made this bot that could play they
could play DotA 1v1 and they brought it
to the biggest
to turn right in the world called the
International and here's one of the best
players in the world his name's dandy
and he's playing one verse one verse
this bar and this bot went like 10 enou
against everybody but this is one of the
best players in the world and he's
getting [ __ ] cream like he doesn't
have a single chance against this bod
russia's he's on the right the bots on
the left excited its infancy
i can really not intervene at all I give
up giving up yeah I can steer like
recognizable team I've seen it quite a
lot this week and okay value away this
was at the end of a long one we won
battle that was the second round against
him and he getting creamed is he a the
bot is on another level and this is one
of the best players in the world and
obviously the bot has the ability to
make decisions immediately doesn't have
to think about anything doesn't have to
think about taking a healing or doing an
attack or calculating range but that's
why it's so terrifying yeah all
immediate it's yeah the bot doesn't need
time to think when you give my humans
tasks and it learns to do it it there
they're so vastly like if you have a
true AI they're going to look at us like
frigate then we have the intellect of a
mouse you know everything immediately
makes sense to them they calculate and
rationalize any problem immediately and
it's and our brains are just pathetic I
mean ultimately so the danger is there I
can see that for sure if it if a machine
somehow gets past a moral barrier that's
coded into itself
who knows what decisions it's going to
optimize if
if humanity or life on earth becomes
part of its optimization code yeah for
whatever purpose it sees who [ __ ]
knows you know Elin says he's afraid
that humans will become second-class
citizens to robots it's essentially like
a dystopian matrix more stored Susan -
yeah it sector exactly was world Susan
so here's the engineer of that bot
basically explaining what happened
comprehend this
these are prone planes he's a human
brain someone is telling me this
variable has failed so many times it's
actually better than professional dota
player it's putting four really
lifetimes of experience and it's quite
so many games of dota as exploring many
different strategies learn to be learn
to exploit other people debate and it's
just played far more into the strategy
as any human as so turns out worried
about star deeply how they just played
dota 24 hours a day don't need us if you
can do in the second time so I find that
explanation was actually really
interesting or fascinating should I say
fascinating because it's like this bot
can just play DotA lifetimes in the span
of like a year even that's right how
long I think they were doing it for for
well a year or less okay in a year they
can play a hundred lifetimes of straight
dota you know and as an amount of
experience that no human could ever
achieve no amount of date you know it's
it's pretty interesting stuff they say
is that next year during the next
international they're going to try to
make a full five-man team to compete
against the best team in the world
that's going to be something to watch
yeah you know they're going to win the
bottom to win right else
so then Zuckerberg Mark Zuckerberg my
favorite person who represents my
favorite company cancer book started
talking [ __ ] on my boy Elon and I'm like
what does Zuckerberg I don't like
Zuckerberg I don't like his company I
don't like a stupid smarmy face and I
don't like other things about him
he says about Elon basically our main
reason is freebooting on Facebook right
among their among many others is our own
device that's just like the it's the
best example of how they do business on
Facebook I think so
the fact they let that go and they
reward people who do it and pay them is
really representative but they're one of
the most unscrupulous disgusting
companies I think the way they farm data
they don't they've done experiments on
people trying to manipulate their mood
try to sell them products they'll show
them post that they know will make them
sad so they can sell them Kleenex or
whatever for prozac or ice cream or ice
cream so then Mark Zuckerberg starts
getting butthurt at Elon and he says he
says that Elon is being irresponsible
and ridiculous he said this publicly in
a live stream about Elon he called it
fear-mongering and Elon later responds
I've spoken to Zuckerberg about it and
his understand me understanding on the
topic is limited oh it's [ __ ] that's
like that I'm gonna be over that's like
an AI you talking about us right this is
uh not static that's a bottle and
unlimited ending is limited and to be
fair you run Facebook dude what the [ __ ]
do you do except mine my data I put a
dick pic on Facebook so Zuckerberg can
mine it and so apparently and also
ironically Zuckerberg the one is like oh
this guy's fear-mongering [ __ ] this guy
we spoke about a couple weeks ago
Facebook is the one who created these
chat BOTS right and they vented their
own language
yeah to start communicating with each
other and broke the protocol that was
designed for them and had to be shut off
yeah and he's the one being like oh you
fear-mongering he's the one developing
Skynet in his basement and so there's he
actually the beef goes even deeper and I
love this whole story it's great it's a
it's a classic story of good versus evil
in my mind so space X forget about
YouTube John oh my god this is on a
whole nother level SpaceX was Elon space
company well it was responsible for
launching one of their internet beaming
satellites on the Falcon 9 rocket that
blew up upon launch was one of their
failed launches and that was Facebook's
satellite that was going to go fly over
Africa and give everybody free access to
the Internet
known as Facebook's free basics and so
that satellite got blown up when the
Falcon 9 failed to launch and exploded
um Marx said about that as I'm here in
Africa and my ivory tower in my palace
in Africa and I have an African
beautiful woman Fanning me with a palm
leaf and feeding me grapes like Jabba
the alright again on I'm easily
disappointed to hear that SpaceX launch
failure destroyed our satellite they
would have provided connectivity to so
many entrepreneurs and everyone else
across the continent is that him so I'll
true a sick and amazing that Facebook
was going to launch a satellite over
Africa to give them free internet yeah
but wait it was actually just some
[ __ ] scheme yeah those are the scheme
this is what a scheme was it sounds like
this can would you seriously trust
Facebook the altruistic company to be an
Internet free Internet to engine it's so
shady that India when they launched it
over India banned it
they banned anyone from accessing it
because they called it essentially
digital colonialism it was a data mining
scheme disguised as humanitarian aid
with bloated for targeted companies apps
and get this it was
like you just connect to it and then you
can use the internet you have to use it
using only a Facebook app of course and
then the the data in India was that
apparently almost nobody was connecting
to it for the first time with the
Internet 90% of people are using we're
just out of data and use it as access
Facebook [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm going to save the world I'm here in
Africa I was going to save this this
flea-ridden country thank you I will
take another creep [ __ ] [ __ ] whatever
they caught you know I love that Indian
bandit
they banned his ass they know what's up
and he has been doing good lately
actually I'm proud of India lately they
also passed a bunch of legislation
legislation committing to going solar
and yeah they're very tough they're very
they speak a lot about the global
warming it's good well they're one of
the biggest you know effects telling by
it you know not affect that yeah but
they're burning a lot of coal but
they're developing country it's hard
anyway that's yeah that's a whole
different thing but anyway I just love
that that Marx trying to make it seem
like this guy just kill all the internet
for Africa so yeah that's about it and
yesterday you had a little heart attack
right when when your phone beeped
and you got a Twitter notification oh
god this was so fun so I'm on my phone
last night
preparing for this podcast today and on
Twitter it says Elon Musk followed you
back and this wasn't no fake [ __ ] like
it's it was verified Elon Musk at Elon
Musk follow you back and I was like
either way she was nothing like yo stop
open Twitter and man I don't know if I
got goofed if it was a bug if he had
like accidentally followed me then
unfollowed me broke my heart man
he didn't phone basically you think that
you know I'm just saying for the people
listening no he's not so currently
follow me yeah what do you think happens
because I'm a hundred sure I saw you on
must follow you but if you're sure that
it said they followed you back it said
that so I think maybe II follow you by
mistake
and then unfollowed because you didn't
know like it clicks on a stake somehow
oh man is person well he's pretty much
my probably my number one most is our
guest the guy is deep into everything I
care about he's at the heart of it and
let me tell you this about you on keys
fascinating fascinating thank you dim
anyway that's pretty much what I have
for today I hope you guys enjoyed that
now it is time to bring in the news with
Dan let's take a short break and then
we'll just hop on to the news with Dan
to wrap up the show so we'd be back in a
quick two minutes my friends stay tuned
welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
weekly top of the week our new episode I
hope you guys are enjoying it we're back
with the news with dan dan why don't you
take us off people who probably heard
but over the last 10 years or so there's
been a lot of research into using magic
mushrooms in therapy you know it
apparently has been proven that it can
be effective at treating people with
PTSD and depression and a multitude of
other conditions and everything and
researchers have just discovered this
breakthrough where they can essentially
synthesize the enzyme that makes you
trip the [ __ ] out when you're taking
mushrooms so now it can be kind of put
into medicine and done and you know a
more clinical way than eating nasty dirt
mushrooms so you don't you don't need to
eat cow pies anymore cow pies yeah right
but it will trip you out the same if you
take the medicine that's what they're
saying
essentially this is the this is the
active ingredient so to speak in
those cow pies or mushrooms that grow on
cow pies that uh that you know
completely makes you trip the [ __ ] out
and so yeah basically you know a lot of
very reputable research institutes have
said that this legitimately is one of
the best methods that they've ever seen
when used in a clinical environment
they're not saying everybody should take
mushrooms behind you know if somebody
you know suffering depression or has
severe PTSD in the right environment
with the therapists there with you kind
of babysitting your trip you can kind of
talk through it and by the time you come
out of the experience you're actually
feeling much better and they they say in
the article I think they said they found
it to be effective up to about six
months well right so you guys get a
great one every six months or something
like that and you're good yep you just
go in and drip all tri-annual
I mean answer the doctor I've heard that
before
I've heard they also do medical tests
with MDMA without sweating good I'd like
if it's ready to sign up sign up for
that doctor I got a couple cow pies for
you it's really interesting you know
it's cool to see these drugs that have
been previously such strong stigma
around an actual medical professional
being like what there's actually
something we can do with this especially
if you live in the controlled
yeah environment that by the way let me
stress this this isn't saying go out and
take these drugs is going to make you
feel there that is not it's not you have
to do it in a controlled environment
with the professional that being said if
you go out to the forest and look for
giant cow dumps you may get lucky all
right cool great interesting story
what's up next when we have up here next
we've got North Korea right so you have
to be living under a rock to not have
heard of this but you know this this was
a big deal in the last week and felt
like something we should probably touch
on you know tensions with north
yeah in this kind of rhetoric of Lego
we're going to bomb you has been going
on forever right like it's at the point
where everybody just kind of rolls their
eyes like sure the difference this time
is apparently North Korea has
miniaturized their nuclear weapon small
enough that in theory they could put
this on a missile and hit the
continental United States especially
relevant for us here because they you
know what caught my eye is they keep
mentioning you know Los Angeles that's
that's in range so this feels a little
different this time because of that they
backed off WOM to threaten so an
tensions have stabilized there they're
no longer threatening to bomb Guam
dangle for Guam at respect it's easy to
see that like oh nothing was ever going
to happen but again every time prior to
this we could say oh nothing's going to
happen because nothing can happen now it
can happen now they they have the
technology to nuke us [ __ ] it I'm going
back to Israel in there just a identify
left Israel to beautiful Los Angeles by
the way when that was wrong the [ __ ] did
WOM do good like battle we're gonna long
long big WOM sort of like what the [ __ ]
we do mom's like a u.s. territory they
can't even vote they're basically just
slaves to America
yes I'm gonna bomb well my guys when
you're using the wall street journal'
prince inside let me know someone point
going like that out hawk oh that's right
you guys portal ministry there I just
quickly get off that story right away
I'm kidding what else did you have
anything else dad uh no just that I
don't want to get new I guess I mean
that's the fair point
death by nuke is kind of may not be the
worst way to go I mean you'll get
anywhere you won't get over here if
you're oh my god these ads um yeah it
really depends where you are but I
I'd look I mean getting vaporized
quick-and-dirty right
anyway what else we got
alright and then this one I want to say
made me happy because that's kind of
dark but the game hunter trampled to
death by elephant in Nam media no media
that's a country that I've heard of
that's what I decided
ignorant good luck I shouldn't shoot him
like relish in the fact that I've never
heard of this country this place on
earth nom nom nom
I know Nam BIA is that nomming I'm a
certain ambiance what I thought it says
but I mean now that I'm looking at it
alright there's a place out there called
Nam Joo 90s don't ever forget it
so yeah this guy from Argentina went
hunting elephants because that's still a
thing people do apparently oh yeah and
uh you know I'm not relishing in his
death necessarily but you gotta love the
irony right I mean and people that go
out and do big-game hunting I'm
relishing in it and how give a guy a
just film [ __ ] no looks like the
elephant [ __ ] him up look we all go
out for that because usually they're
like from far away and they're not even
doing anything it's just they just pay
someone to hunt for them and then they
take a picture with the dead anymore
like they did something that yeah I mean
that may have been the case here but
they just [ __ ] up but it's when you're
on this big-game hunt right the whole
point is like miiverse to animal that's
the whole point and how how long side it
is that game how often does the human
lose well guess what boys today the
human loss human law yeah it's under
even if you're like it's an underdog
story everybody loves an underdog story
[ __ ] that guy he went out there shaking
his dick trying to get his his [ __ ]
nut off feel like a big man killing a
beautiful immaculate majestic elephant I
really don't get these people really
don't get it yeah I did the whole thing
is so weird they paid thousands of
dollars and then the whole thing is
it uptake they go they meet these people
or locals and the locals tell them
exactly where the animals going to be
it's all organized them yeah you you
spend here the animal will be there and
that you just click this thing and then
you have a picture right $20,000 qui we
tranquilized that animal he subdued he
all a on the ground all you have to do
is go to deliver the final blow I
masturbate with his blood yes we do love
that does well can't even argue that
it's the thrill of you know stalking
through the brush and you know tracking
this animal for miles on end and taking
it down or whatever I mean that's so
[ __ ] up but you can make an argument
that that's like a you know thrilling
experience or something but this is it I
mean it's just handed to you on a silver
platter just hey like like you said you
just pull the trigger just hey you get
to kill this thing I'm not gonna I'm not
denouncing all hunting like some is fine
I'm talking specifically about this guy
so it's this rich people who pay like
twenty thousand dollars to go shoot some
really exotic I have like like
announcement a like auction off the
rights to kill one exotic government and
the money goes to conservation
quote-unquote which means the local
governments back pocket where you know
and elephants are essentially non-human
intelligent life elephants are one of
the most intelligent creatures on earth
they recognize those Amir's they have
complex language and culture you know
it's an argument in my opinion an
elephant killing Alvin is kind of murder
same with like a dolphin quote same with
like a [ __ ] gorilla I mean it's kind
that you're murdering a nonhuman
creature I know there's not many
non-human creatures in my opinion who
are sentient on an ear level as us but
elephants are one of them certainly
absolutely but you know there's invasive
there's overpopulation there's deer and
shed that's perfectly acceptable to go
hunt yeah but this [ __ ] is weird anyway
you got [ __ ] killed what happened
trampled so he took a shot he took a
shot and he [ __ ] missed and elephant
took him out
pretty much said the hunter identified
as a 48 year old Jose mandalas was
killed on Saturday afternoon in a
private wildlife area 43 miles northwest
of a small town and calc Feld
the dude worked for an oil company class
act
Wow if I got charged well they all died
with another Argentinian and three Nam
beings working and me me wait wait whose
work wait what clarified the that's how
you say I guess I I don't I don't
believe they all died was I was wildly
so the elephant was like [ __ ] this guy
in particular yeah and this is a this
kind of things kind of to your point of
how they're near sentient elephants that
are kind of in these areas that this
goes on the ones that survive they they
hold grudges essentially and there's
even been stories of them you know
essentially attacking villages in what
kind of activity a pseudo organized
manner where they'll you know they'll
mess up and charge you know in a wall of
elephants and you know mess without
event and that's what humans would do
right and it was kind of like the same
in fjords with the Shamu and the killer
whales the few times the killer whales
actually killed the the trainers right
because it's like [ __ ] you Lavery stop
bossing me around and free me yeah yeah
mmm on some level they understand I
think
yeah and killer whales are one of them
too yeah you know well that's just my
opinion folks and that we need like a
slogan and that's the way it goes down
well that's our show that's our Tuesday
show hope you guys had fun let us know
what you thought we'd think we're gonna
keep doing it every week I like the
balance here between having us doing our
thing here and having a guest yeah
Friday it's a good balance to beat to be
truthful with you my dream although it's
far off now is to do it every weekday
but that's a far oh that's that's flat
farmer that is a fascinating fascinating
but for now it's a to date
I like that balance for now we should
call this a bit fascinating show this is
the fascination hour I found it really
fascinating
the fascination hour guys anyway I hope
you all had a good time or get a laugh
happy Wednesday my dudes
see you on Friday for Jay Paul and the
key t8 reporter looking forward to that
until then my friends I shall be calling
you with my thoughts and prayers and to
everybody who has supported us
graciously through Amazon twitch Prime I
will think of you the next time I make
love by my friend